para asignar tareas en mis clases de
khan academy
lo primero es seleccionar la clase desde
la cual quiero enviar la tarea hago clic
en la clase
y se me va a abrir a abrir el menú
principal de mi clase tenemos tareas
progreso porque esta es una misión
actividad lista configuración se hago
clic en tareas se despliega la lista de
las tareas que he asignado para asignar
una nueva nos vamos a la parte inferior
y vamos a hacer click en el botón azul
que dice encuentra contenido de álgebra
para asignar al hacer clic e
inmediatamente se nos abre
una nueva ventana en donde tenemos todas
las opciones de los conceptos que los
alumnos deben aprender en álgebra de
aquí puedo yo seleccionar cuál es el
concepto que quiero que mis estudiantes
practiquen si yo selecciono por ejemplo
propiedad asociativa de la
multiplicación cuando yo coloco el
cursor sobre el concepto del lado
derecho superior vamos a encontrar los
vídeos relacionados a ese concepto que
también podemos asignar de tarea a
nuestros alumnos basta con hacer clic en
el vídeo para que podamos asignar si yo
quiero seleccionar un ejercicio hago
clic en el concepto que quiero que
practiquen y automáticamente se abre el
ejercicio y en la parte superior vemos
un menú
con toda la información para asignar la
tarea lo primero que voy a elegir es a
qué clase voy a asignar esta tarea en
este caso voy a poner a demo conalep y
voy a poner también a que estudiantes
aquí poder seleccionar a todos mis
estudiantes o bien a determinados
estudiantes que quiero que practiquen en
particular este concepto y en esta
opción voy a seleccionar la fecha de
entrega cuál es la fecha de vencimiento
de esta tarea si me voy hacia abajo
puedo seleccionar también a la hora de
entregar horas quiero que le entregué y
una vez que tengo ya esta información
hago clic en asignar si yo pretendo
guardar esta tarea para más adelante
porque aún no estoy lista para asignar
la hago clic en guardar y la tarea será
guardada en un listado especial para
poder utilizarla más tarde en este caso
hago clic en asignar
y voy a mi listado de tareas
en el momento que yo asignó una tarea
los alumnos reciben un correo
avisándoles de esta tarea cuando ellos
abren la tarea les dan la opción de
poder
contestar y responder la tarea desde su
correo electrónico
este es nuevamente mi listado de tareas
como maestro aquí puedo ver que ya se
agregó la tarea a mí a mi listado aquí
me indica cuando lo asigne cuántos
alumnos de mi total lo han contestado y
tengo aquí un botón de acciones que si
yo hago clic veo que puedo editar esta
tarea
puedo cambiar la fecha de entrega
etcétera o bien puedo copiar esta tarea
y en este caso se crea una tarea
idéntica para ser asignada en otra clase
o bien desde aquí también puedo borrar
la tarea recuerden que en el momento que
yo optó por borrar una tarea se borra no
solo de mi listado sino también del
listado de los alumnos
en esta parte superior vemos tres
opciones activo vencido guardado en la
parte de activo tengo todas las tareas
que están activas en la parte de vencido
todas aquellas tareas que ya vencieron y
desde aquí puedo ver qué alumnos la
contestaron que alumnos no en el momento
en que un alumno contesta se abre esta
opción de ver reporte si yo hago clic en
mi reporte me va a abrir todos los
ejercicios que los alumnos contestaron y
desde aquí me dice qué porcentaje de
alumnos lo contestaron bien si hago clic
en esta parte me dice que alumnos el
cual en cuántos intentos lo contestaron
bien
cuando yo voy a mi perfil y eso lo hago
haciendo clic en mi nombre desde aquí yo
puedo acceder a mi panel como estudiante
oa mi panel como tutor si yo hago clic
en mi panel en el panel de inicio el
aprendizaje me llevan para mi papá como
alumno y como podrán ver los alumnos al
entrar al entrar ahí hacer sesión en
khan academy inmediatamente se les abre
un listado también de todas las tareas
vencidas y futuras que tienen que
completar y aquí únicamente tienen que
hacer clic en empezar para poder
responder la tarea entonces para ellos
es verdaderamente muy fácil tener acceso
a las tareas enviadas
muchas gracias